did not invite these stolen
with Valentine's Day again everyone get
some action how exciting yeah
our duck John with capital rated-r
starts Friday you want to know don't you
why they can come in here where are the
others
once you're hiding I don't sell out
friend
you won't die
and then rhyme
[Music]
the secrets
money makers I
are you recording oh it's going on
watch the new trailer now at Life movie
calm yes he killed actually I was just
leaving another diagnosis
and you will see wonderful tea
well that pretty dark yeah
rough night last night jock with Chapter
two wicked are in Peters Friday who in
the hell do you think you are
that was awesome
[Music]
hold it what's that he says welcome to
the frickin guardians of the galaxy
holy you didn't use fricken look out oh
wow
I tried dress
when I'm in the trumpet back I'm on a
rise whether out of the breath ain't no
grave can hold my body down
what do you think I'm the affairs of a
and coming
a no gray
general
pirates live there ain't no grave hello
my buddy
[Music]
you
[Music]
we are Dominic Toretto just went rogue
you gonna turn your back on family
I'm thinking you down so write out one
play like that
you gotta catch da you got any little
help you want to tell me why you just
put me in a room with this criminal you
don't think that type a [ __ ] kind of the
circulation you're lying you should get
bigger size you guys are going to work
together all the way just going to give
up today
Oh
fire
I don't wanna go swimming or dodge your
rollers yeah
are you tired of not feeling well
take the Cure and give back your life
that effects include drowsiness weight
loss nausea skin eruptions anxiety
severe solution
halation murderous rage in addition of
in 12 a.m.
take the QI radar while you're watching
the game they are watching the bay
welcome to Baywatch you people to
lifeguard not believe you people can say
that you're just dad I don't come on bub
why did he was the quickest running
[Music]
ready to do this hell yeah
whoa whoa were you wearing freedom
that's desecration
you